alrighty everyone the latest uh
uncharted movie trailer the first
uncharted movie trailer just dropped um
this is tom holland very pleased to
announce that i finally bought youtube
red so i don't have to have ads that i
have to skip at the start of all of
these videos
um i
feel like similarly to a lot of people
i've been
unsure about tom holland playing nathan
drake i don't know how i feel about it
but i am open-minded so i'm hoping that
we see some cool stuff in this trailer
uh going in with you know just like um
not a lot of hype not a lot of
expectation but
enthusiasm so
let's watch shall we this is uh i'm
watching it on the official playstation
youtube channel here today and i guess
it published at some point this morning
so
let's do it
they have the plane sequences out there
you can't find on any map
they're not gone
they're just lost
the production value looks good
unsurprisingly i suppose
hey kid i'm a little young for a
bartender aren't you a little old for
prom aren't you
falling all around
everything in here why the map this path
of ferdinand magellan took the sail
around the world you know your history
i do really like him as sully
5 billion easy
[Music]
i think you're here because you're your
brother well you know my brother's sick
[Music]
i didn't expect that to be referenced to
sam oh i guess maybe that's the
motivation for him
yeah that makes sense
character motivation beyond just
i'm a friend of sully's sally doesn't
have any friends i should know him one
of them
[Music]
your parkour stuff could be cool well i
dabble i don't know
my family has been looking for this
portion for a very long time so much
blood
i'm pretty sure he's just threatened to
kill me don't touch your ear like that
you look like an idiot
you have no idea who you partnered with
i've been dreaming about this stuff
since i was a kid my brother's saying
left one final clue
oh god
oh that that's very cool
i wonder how they shot that
that's awesome
[Music]
oh my god i come out to play with that
big boy's way in because you're about to
get a proper scottish welcome
what
[Music]
crap
exclusively in movie theaters i have
thoughts this is interesting i think
that um
no matter what i think tom holland is in
a tough spot
because he got famous really really
quickly i actually don't think he's too
young to play a young nathan drake it's
just that kind of we look at him as a
baby and he got famous so fast that it's
difficult not to just see
tom holland um
which
sucks for him really um but
there are moments in this where
he's not peter parker he's not
spider-man he
like this line here
oh my god i should never come out to
play with that big boy's way in cause
you're about to get a proper scottish
welcome
what
that's totally how nolan north would
deliver that line um even though oh my
god is not that different and there was
something else in here that i was like
you know what his delivery actually is
different um
even if we look at him as like oh this
is tom holland and you know it was
really hard for people like daniel
radcliffe to get away from that kind of
thing
um it's difficult for me to picture this
dude as
nathan drake when
in my head i know exactly what nathan
drake looks like and exactly how nathan
drake sounds
but he is playing a character you can
see it if you look for it i think um
yeah i really don't think his age is an
issue it's what i keep seeing people
comment on us his age but i actually
really don't think that's the problem it
is the recognizability of tom holland
and the issue disconnecting him from
the spider-man version of tom holland
which seems to be very similar to who he
is as a real person whereas
this he does seem a little bit sharper a
little less of the awkward peter stuff
um
in any of this which i'm very glad to
see history
it's the biggest treasure that's never
been found five billion easy
he's not doing the awkward stuff that
that spider-man does is kind of my point
so
in terms of this as like a whole trailer
um
putting aside like i'm i'm okay with tom
holland i think
i think he is doing nathan drake-esque
stuff
um
but i i like the other two and i know
them it's it's odd i feel like yeah
again i i
think it's the recognizability of tom
holland that's the problem um but in in
terms of the entire trailer
i actually don't think this is a super
interesting trailer if you take away
the amount of us that are fans of
uncharted um
like if you're watching through this
trailer let me just
mute it and play it back again
for me i'm i'm picturing the video game
i'm picturing like
moments from any of the uncharted games
of course and i know the relationships
between these characters and i'm looking
out for those things
but if you remove
the uncharted fan in me
and i don't go oh
these characters that i know oh cool i
know what they're gonna do i know sam um
that's trey baker who i do a podcast
with
i feel like this trailer is not
it doesn't feel very different from
necessarily
any
other
treasure hunter movie um
[Music]
like this feels like fan service one
thousand percent i mean ignoring the
fact that he's getting out of the water
shirtless but
yeah i don't know that i i love the
trailer overall outside of being like oh
that could be cool oh i'm looking at
this from the perspective of a fan
i don't know
i don't i think i maybe can't separate
myself from it and maybe maybe other
audiences won't feel that way but like
it does look like there's a lot of
similarity to the games which is super
exciting um i have
no doubt that naughty dog is
taking this super seriously as well and
it does seem like sony pictures is going
to do this with more video game
properties going forward because
tsushima
is happening as well
i this is so exciting to me but yeah i
do wonder what people who aren't um
[Music]
uncharted fans would think of this like
what is it really about other than
treasure hunting is kind of my my
question
um
which is not a new thing for films at
all i mean obviously uncharted is copied
off of indiana jones
which is funny with the internet indiana
jones game being made because now
they're going to be like yo just
uncharted oh my
god never come out to play with that big
boy's way in because you're about to get
a proper scottish welcome
what
i do really like that that lion read
more than anything else is selling me on
on
him sounding more like nolan which is
super interesting um
so yeah overall
i'm alright with it i think
not super sold on it as a film in terms
of why do i need this beyond
everything uncharted that i already have
i mean i think it's cool but if we want
video game movies to succeed they need
to be really really really good movies
this is clearly very good production
value again
um but does this trailer appeal to
people who aren't uncharted fans i
really don't know
um let's make the terrible decision of
scrolling down to
what just happened did my discord just
make a noise
i have no idea what just did that um
let's make the terrible decision of
reading comments shall we
weird decision to start off with
uncharted 4 but morphed into a prequel
that is true obviously that uh cave
scene at the beginning is uncharted 4
esque the the um
i don't remember the names of any of the
locations despite that being the one
that i played the most recently like the
the fancy
the heist area
um
i i think it works i mean obviously
uh the plane is not
uncharted 4 and he's not wearing the
uncharted 4
clothing
people confused about the timeline if
it's a prequel why are we meeting sully
now
uh
i would say this is not canon um to
jibby jenkins here saying we know how
nate met sally from uncharted 3 is this
canada isn't it in my opinion this is
not canon at all this is an uncharted
movie that will be a totally separate
thing agreed that it is three and four
together no signs of one and two yeah
plane is obviously from three
yeah i don't
i don't think that we should take this
as though it's
it's canon um i never expected it to be
taken canon
huge fan of uncharted games look like
sony kept true to those uncharted game
moments that made it epic but not a fan
of tom holman and mark wahlberg nathan
fillion was born to play nathan drake
there's still
hope in considering tom holland is
playing young nathan drake um
something about nathan phillian that i
heard
uh just from one source i don't haven't
verified this but
um
i heard
that nathan fillion was approached
to play
uh nathan drake
and said no
he didn't want anything to do
with um making a video game that was
back when actors were like garbage and
he didn't he didn't want to do it and
then
apparently
when uncharted became really popular and
nathan fillion realized how big it was
then he came back around and was like
let me play this um but naturally when
you've already passed on something
because you're like video game no
that relationship is a little bit uh a
little bit different but i'm not again
i've only heard that from one person
um i'm not positive that that is
actually true
but it is somebody who
uh worked on uncharted in the past
character of nathan's voice is so
important i don't know that that's true
this this is the thing that i don't know
that i agree with so josh harper's
saying tom doesn't have a mature cocky
charming rich voice that nolan north
provided for the games he seems too
young i think we're all getting caught
up in how young he does look um but i
still think that's because we we met him
when he was young and he became famous
when he was young i think he can get
away with mature cocky and charming i
don't know about the rich voice that
nolan has nolan obviously has an
incredible voice um i'm friends with
nolan north and even talking to him in
person he's he's got a lovely voice
so does troy
uh mark looks more like nate than sally
that's true but i don't think it matters
they don't have to look exactly the same
this is a very good point that that line
doesn't really make any sense sully
doesn't have any friends i should know
i'm one of them
it does seem like um
most people
tend to agree and none of this is
is too aggressive i do like tom holland
but i feel like he's miss casters nathan
drake which i think is kind of how
i feel everyone is unsure about tom
holland i feel like i saw pieces of
things that could work in there but it
didn't prove to me that i'm going to
like it um
i i did think that the
ties to uh the games were really cool
and it was fun to see those and i'm
interested
in that like as a fan but i'm just not
sure if i'm interested in it as
a film goer like is this on my list of
things to watch
i don't know
i would have liked to have seen some
more jokes for sure yeah to see
nathan drake making more jokes being
that cocky arrogant guy
but i do i am more comfortable with the
thought that tom holland can do it now
after seeing this than i was previously
whereas previously i was like
[Music]
um
seems like more of a crash cash grab
than a movie for actual uncharted fans i
don't agree with that at all i think
this is a movie for uncharted fans
and i imagine naughty dog did have a
hand in the production
tom's soft voice doesn't fit drake at
all
i don't know i'm really not sure i think
it's possible that we just aren't used
to it and it's different and different
isn't inherently bad
it's not like i love it you know like i
would have loved nathan fillion but i
don't hate it either
i feel like
i've just overanalyzed the hell out of
this i want to go talk to people about
it please let me know in the comments
what you guys think this is something
that i feel like i need to like figure
out my thoughts on more and like
do i want to see it you know i'm sure i
will but
i don't really know how i feel i don't
really know how i feel
um hey it looks like it's great
production quality and
yeah i was a fan there were some cool
moments in there but um not sure
overall i feel like i want to hear more
people's perspectives and talk to more
people about it and
see what i think um alrighty that is it
for me today i can't believe i spoke
about a 2 minute 33 second trailer for
14 minutes
wow look at us go
oops